[Music]
and where's that going to be
we're going to
[Music]
very important
the genes that we've been involved
I have been partially dependent Jeannie
[Music]
and healthcare division
the airplane engine surgical because
that was here and here's what was you
baby
you make it go yeah well I'll change
freedom
[Music]
rather that's our person anguish
makes like let me help you
[Music]
first track
how do we actually help out so what you
see behind town
first week
the face shield
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody hi
[Music]
just talking about it we have a very big
stuck file right now and we're building
it bigger and we're helping a lot of
other countries Nigeria we just sent a
thousand we have various various
countries France Spain we have a lot
going to Italy we have a lot going to a
different probably 1518 countries
they're calling us we had the capacity
to do this nobody else did so every
state now has more than they need and
our stockpile is totally full we have a
tremendous amount so now we're really
helping other countries with it
you know losing a lot of people because
they don't have ventilators a ventilator
is hard to do and I want to say that
Ford and General Electric have done an
incredible job working together and also
the companies that work with you they
really did they did a great job they do
a great car and they do they really did
a great job on the ventilator and I hear
that the quality of the ventilator has
been really top-of-the-line thank you
mister we really appreciate it though
mr. president there was a lot of
interest about whether you would end up
wearing
today could you just take us through
your thought process and why he decided
not well I did where I had going on
before I pour one in this back area but
I didn't want to give the press the
pleasure of seeing it but no but I had
it in the back here I did put save as
did you have the goggles on too as well
sir I did here's another one because in
this area I would you'd like wearing it
here first
I'm not necessary here what everybody's
been tested and I've been tested in fact
I was tested this morning but so it's
not necessary but the executive there
well that's interest I was given I was
given a choice and I had one on in an
area where they preferred it so I put it
on and it was very nice very nice but
they said not necessary example I think
it sets an example both ways and as they
say I did have
[Music]
[Applause]
I just like your question so you know
what who is such a nice question no it's
a great question here's a question for
you
so I've seen her make a very good we've
seen the manufacturers here for others
small businesses turning things over how
do you see what's taking places this is
the biggest mobilization since the world
war since World War two and these people
were in charge of it they did it they
did a fantastic job they did a really
fantastic job and we appreciate it all
of these companies they came together
and they used to make cars here they
used to make other things here and now
they're not only event players but
you're saying the masks and all of the
other present what other product you
make at a Ford but not bad not a bad
position
yeah so we've got our super 9 oh hi
Carol all right you know what we're
making we've got the the pressure
respirators obviously the ventilators
the masks the gowns you know we really
anything that anybody needs we responded
quickly and we're very proud of our
workforce they've been amazing is he
doing a good job
years of chairman CEO the company here
how does this crisis dealing with this
pandemic making PP materials compare
well everyone's different I mean you
think you know I won't take you through
all of them going all the way back to
you know maybe the oil shocks and and
then the you know the dot-com meltdowns
and all this every crisis is different
but what's amazing is how our people
respond and then this one they didn't
wait to be asked to do something they
said here's an opportunity and let's go
with what I love about our culture is
they didn't ask for permission they just
went and that's something that we've
done throughout our 117 year history and
I hope will always do by the way
beautiful where's my where's my ministry
and I liked it very much
absolutely honestly I think I look
better in the math gonna make any but
I'm making a speech so I won't have it
now but I did have a going right here I
think some of you might have gotten a
shot thank you can you confirm that the
president was told it's okay not to wear
one in this area it's okay
[Music]
we shipped 887 salikus seatbelt
something
[Music]
the ventilator in the respirator
how many will you make a week mental
speculators
[Music]
so close to 6000 ventilators a week
think of that from a running start which
wasn't much of a run actually so we had
very few of this country almost none we
were not in that business and now
they're making thousands a week great
thing
[Music]
so basically this is the maximum
protection for maximally blows filtered
air
[Music]
so there hang on
we got to get back to the rally's agree
with a John what course mr. president
the rally's more question the secretary
of the Treasury said there is a strong
likelihood that we'll need another
fiscal stimulus - you're thinking what
shape would that take if we will I think
we're going to be helping people out
look at our beginning some money for
them during the artificial because it
really is it's an artificial closure and
now we're going to be able to open it up
this is it like for long-term problems
and then takes years and years to having
come back the Depression took 12 years
for 14 15 years I'm gonna be back next
year maybe even in the fourth water a
few months we're going to be back
because whether it week we closed it and
now we open it but I would say there
could be one more nice shot way more
nice and what do you think should be in
well I'd like you know and I have
exactly I know exactly but I'd rather do
it at the appropriate we know if they
are celebrating these great companies
doing ventilators and other equipment
but we have a very very specific plan
and it'll be great for the American
people and our economy is going to be
back soon and Ford and General Electric
and these great companies that helped us
so much in a time of need
they're going to be very happy
and you're already gearing up you know I
know you're gearing up your alliance is
starting to roll making cars again so a
lot of things are happening by the way
on our southern border it's never been
so secure we're up to almost 200 miles
of wall and we have never had that whole
area is nobody comes through that area
the area where the wall goes up that's
the end of that and so you're fearful
you're having this feature this
afternoon what what are you thinking
about in terms of campaign rallies when
will you be able to get back to so as
soon as you're able to have people get
in you know we've never had an empty
seat since the day I came down the
escalator with our future first lady
we've never had an empty seat you know
that and would have thousands of people
we sent away and I think the demand half
of what we see is greater than ever
before we're gonna have to go to certain
states where we were able to look I
don't want to have a stadium where
you're supposed to have a person and
then seven empty seats and then another
person so we might do some outdoor big
ones and we may also just wait till the
stadium's can open up I think it's going
to be soon we'll go to a place like
Florida we'll go to a place like maybe
George or some other place where they're
going to be opening up whoever it opens
up first the demand has been incredible
to get going with the rallies they just
hear the music in the background I'm
saying
we've been rallies like nobody's ever
had and we would love to get back to
that I think it's going to be sooner
you were asked about this briefly this
morning this name is AstraZeneca back cm
Oxford the rate that HHS has invested 1
billion dollars in how much promise do
you think that holds for an early
vaccination I think it holds tremendous
promise but we have many of the
companies who are just about as far
along we have many companies we have the
greatest pharmaceutical companies in the
world of their equal they get I mean
they're really in a position and I'm
only I'm not only talking about vaccine
I'm talking about cures and therapeutics
therapeutically we have some things
coming out which we think is going to be
great but that to be tested quickly who
anyway we're doing it very quick who
would get the vaccine
first first responders elderly feet
right now what we're doing is we're
setting what logistically with our
military our military is in here so that
we can give 150 200 million shots
quickly in militaries in gear you know
we can move a couple of hundred thousand
soldiers immediately in time of
emergency so this is not nearly as big a
deal as that it's equally as important
perhaps but it's not it's not as tough
to just say but how would you prioritize
I'll sit down with a lot of people who
will figure it out we're going to sit
down with the military and we hope to be
in that position fairly soon so rather
than having the vaccine doing the tests
and then starting to gear up we're
taking a risk because you know it could
be that if something happened but I
don't think that's going to be but in
addition to that company we have other
companies that are very far advanced and
also don't forget therapeutics and cure
we're talking about a vaccine in this
case and therapeutics and cure
and frankly that's my first choice
because that would take care of people
that are in trouble right now
mr. president I'm on the issue of
testing there's been questions about
whether you're satisfied or not with
what the CDC is doing the work they're
doing particularly the director dr. Fran
fume can you address that
are you satisfied I think they're doing
a good job a really good job in a very
complex situation you know we started
off nobody knew what the virus was it
came in from China nobody knew what it
was and frankly I think they've done a
really good job I'm very happy about it
a lot of other people think they've done
a lot of you know great work we're now
up to and this is beyond even CDC
because we've done it between Jared
Kushner and a lot of geniuses coming in
from Silicon Valley and a lot of people
these companies where they could make
ventilators and or look what we did with
ventilators is incredible because we
dared up in a short period of time
through General Electric Ford they're
represented here at the top level
through other companies we were at
Honeywell the other day they make masks
who would think Honeywell is making a
mask but that's what they're making now
is a mask it's a very high-tech company
you know they make their the dashboards
to an airplane and lots of other things
and now they're making masks our
company's geared up so quickly so fast
Honeywell opened a plant in three weeks
from literally zero to open making masks
and three websites spend an incredible
achievement there's never been anything
done like this since the end of
you as you said descended number of
weeks ago we can't let the Cure become
worthless truly disease where are where
are we in that convent I think I was the
first one to say it I don't know would
you say that I was the first one but you
can't let the Cure become worse than the
problem itself the world I think we have
to I think the governor's have to start
opening up we now know the disease we
know the weaknesses and the strengths we
know that older people are affected
gravely and younger people are not
affected gravely frankly you look at the
statistics it's incredible and we know
that we have to protect some people much
more so I think a lot of the governor's
have done a very very poor job or
nursing homes but they've done a good
job on other things I know every
governor I can give you I can bring in
every governor but we've made a lot of
hero governor's we've done a great job
for the governors and my relationship
with them in almost all cases is very
good and remember this one of the
beauties we just document not one person
who needed a ventilator didn't get a
mental but with another 2.4 million
people claiming first unemployment
benefits today how close are we to the
cure being worse than the disease I
think that a lot of these states that
the ones in are sort of sticking to a
certain very rigid pattern I think
they're gonna stop I don't think the
people are going to stand for it this is
a country that's meant to be open that
close and we did the right thing John we
saved millions of lives millions and
millions of lives you would have had
anywhere from a million five to two
million 5 3 million lives think of it so
if we were at a hundred thousand instead
of a hundred thousand multiply that
times 15 20 or 25 it wouldn't have been
acceptable it wouldn't have been
sustainable he couldn't have done it so
we've pulled it right and now I want it
open and we're going to open and if
there's a fire and ember a flame
someplace we put it out but the people
have done a great job and General
Electric for did all the other people
that work with them have done fantastic
work and Honeywell again I was here last
week but Honeywell they've done
fantastically well
[Music]
people say that's a very distinct
possibility its standard and we're going
to put out the fires we're not going to
close the country we're going to put out
the fires it could be whether it's an
ember or a flame we're going to put it
out but we're not closing our country
are you looking to replace dr. Redfield
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
to get to the riser guys
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats our program will begin shortly
[Music]
trying to save
do you say
without it
some things are getting better
all the things a little
it's a situation much like a herd
[Music]
[Applause]
sidewalk
[Music]
[Applause]
big wheels down on me
[Music]
[Applause]
I tell you you got to be free
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Ford's Ross and ville components plant
manager Angela weathers
good afternoon everybody and welcome my
name is Angela weathers and I'm the
plant manager here at Ford's Roslyn
ville plant it's great to have you join
us today and thank you for coming
if shalini to honor the work that we
have been doing service to our country
and our company runs throughout our
veins and when this crisis began we all
wanted to find a way to help create the
equipment that the country needed to win
our team has stepped up and worked
tirelessly for a common cause our
workers both hourly and salary have done
their very best to put safety first to
stay safe strong and on the job I do
want to take a moment to ask our team
members to remember all of our health
care workers first responders essential
workforce we have given their lives in
order to serve and protect the public
doing this extraordinary challenge in
our country it has been a privilege
leading this team and I'm so proud to be
part of the Ford Motor Company family
led effortlessly by Bill Ford so without
further ado please help me give a
standing ovation introducing our
executive chairman of Ford Motor Company
Bill Ford
[Applause]
well hello everybody and thank you so
much Angela and thank you for your
tireless leadership you and your team
represent the very best of Ford and
welcome mr. president to Ford's Ross and
Ville plant and welcome to all our
employees who are joining us today today
is a big day for Ford and it's an
important time for our country normally
at this plant we assemble components and
hybrid batteries for Ford cars and
trucks but for the past six weeks our
employees have been assembling machines
to save lives and as everybody here
knows Ford has always been a family
business but it's not just my family
generations of Ford employees have
punched in everyday in plants like this
one building for America and we take
that trust very seriously we have a
special responsibility to take care of
each other and this country just like
we've done for a hundred and seventeen
years in World War two many of our
workers went to fight overseas and those
who couldn't stayed to build war
machines of all types needed to win the
war in plants just like this in fact
President Roosevelt visited our Willow
Run plant a few miles down the road to
honor the Ford workers who were
producing b-24 bombers during World War
two
Ford was called the arsenal of democracy
today some of their grandchildren and
great-grandchildren
are building equipment to save lives and
to protect our medical professionals and
first responders I'm deeply grateful to
all of our employees in Ross and Ville
for stepping up and leading the way when
we paused our factories to keep our
workers and their families safe our
teams began thinking about what they
could do to serve their country
and just as they always have our
employees sprang into action we are the
most American automaker employing more
hourly workers in the US than any other
automaker
[Applause]
we assemble more vehicles in America
than anyone else and we invest more here
and that's why at a moment's notice we
were able to shift gears and put our
manufacturing expertise to work
producing life-saving medical gear and
equipment by tapping our spirit of
innovation Ford engineers worked with 3m
to design powered respirators from
sketch to production in less than 40
days and working with GE healthcare and
the UAW we plan to manufacture 50,000
ventilators right here in this facility
and just down the road we've assembled
over 17 million face shields for our
medical heroes across the country
that's what manufacturing can do and
that's why a strong manufacturing base
is critical for our country and Thank
You mr. president for your support of
American manufacturing this week many of
our assembly lines restarted again with
Ford workers building the cars and
trucks American depends on like the
f-150 and others that you see in this
room actually I think this one might
make a pretty good presidential limo
anyway but what I here's what I want all
of our employees and your families to
know we put as much care and attention
into developing our plan to return to
work as anything I've been involved with
in my 40 years at Ford we consulted the
best medical experts we rethought plant
layouts and we employ technology that
will help keep all of us safe and many
of the concepts that we're deploying
across all our plants were pioneered
right here in Ross and Ville the many
ways our 200,000 employees have stepped
up to help each other and the world
through this pandemic makes me very
proud to call each and one of you a part
of our Ford family America's engines may
have gone quiet over the past few months
but with a new spirit
safety responsibility and innovation
Ford is is proud to start them up again
and now it's my pleasure to introduce
the President of the United States we've
spoken many times over the years and
while we don't always agree on every
issue
he is always considered our opinion he
supported tax cuts which have helped
move the economy forward and we deeply
appreciate his work and leading a new
trade treaty with Mexico and Canada and
there is no doubt that we share a
passionate view that building in America
is the right thing to do for our workers
the economy and the future of this
country mr. president thank you for
joining us here today to celebrate our
workers and this important effort to
help get America through this crisis
[Music]
forget the mood
who came
[Music]
to do
very much I like that Dyess very much
actually it's very special nice wood
beautiful like the dashboards are in
your cars bill right thank you and I
just heard you're gonna be having two
more mm more jobs right down the road
for the Bronco which is a big winner
that's great fantastic job thank you
very much bill thank you thank you
that's right down the road it's an honor
to have bill with us thank you very much
and I'm thrilled to be back in Michigan
we've done a lot of work in Michigan a
lot of plants are opening a lot of
plants stopped we stopped them from
closing and we kept your workers here in
Michigan and in the United States
different places as you know all over
the United States but it's an honor to
do it's one of the reasons I'm standing
here in fact years ago I was honored
long before I ever thought of the
presidential situation I was honored in
Michigan and I said how come you're
losing so much of your car business to
Mexico and other places and I asked that
question very innocently was probably 10
years ago the man of the year they named
me man of the year in Michigan and I
said what's going on in Michigan and
we've stopped it and thanks to a lot of
great companies like Ford a lot of
things are happening here and it's why
I'm so honored when when bill mentioned
the plant that you're going to be doing
2000 and it's also a great success the
Broncos so that's really really big news
thank you very much thank you
and I'm honored to stand on a factory
floor operated by the incredible workers
of Ford Motor Company
you really are tremendously talented
people I know it I'm not sure everybody
in the world knows it but a lot of
people do and they're all going to know
it after this speech but you aren't
really talented great people thank you
very much for doing a great job we know
what it takes few people have that
ability whew
in our nation's war against the
invisible enemy the hard-working
Patriots here today answered the call to
serve you prove that the American worker
is built forward and you are built Ford
Tough a great expression you still use
that expression I think bill right
that's a great expression and your let's
see can I use it for baby myself built
Trump Tufano though they may say that's
the take-off that's no good you can't do
that and you've made really America
proud and you've made Ford proud and
America is very proud of Ford right here
at the Ross and Ville component plant
you're building a great medical arsenal
to defeat the virus and cement America's
place as the leading manufacturer and
exporter of ventilators anywhere in the
world we're now getting calls from other
countries many other countries both
friend and foe believe it or not we get
calls from foe
and we want to help them out too and
we're making thousands and thousands of
ventilators and I think we really sort
of started right over here we got a call
very early on from Bill in the group and
this is incredible what's happened and
what you've done with your help not a
single American who has needed a
ventilator has been denied a ventilator
not one and as you remember we took over
empty cupboards the cupboards were bare
and we got into the business of
ventilators and testing and all of these
other things now we've done 14 million
tests the second country is at three
million and less than 3 million Germany
South Korea and they've done a good job
but we're at 14 million tests and the
tests of the best of all but on behalf
of our entire nation I want to say thank
you very much thank you very much for
doing a great
driven by the love and sweat and
devotion of everyone here today we're
saving lives were forging ahead and as
of this week the beating heart of the
American auto industry is back open for
business that started right away didn't
it starts right now and you have all
those supply chains coming in they're
going to come through because if they
don't come through just build a product
right here okay because you know that
can happen too but we heard that it's a
big story that we're starting with the
cars now and it's going to be a big
success in addition to many wonderful
UAW workers were joined by secretary ben
Carson who's done a fantastic job
where's Ben Ben is here Thank You Ben
where is he oh there he is hi Ben Thank
You Ben thank you
and Amanda's done a fantastic job for
Ford well I've asked Bill about this
later I'll just find out I want to make
sure for myself but I know based on
results I know CEO Jim Hackett Jim thank
you very much the word is yes Jim the
word is great job great job plant
manager Angela weathers Angela thank you
very much that's a big job that's a big
job you enjoy it yeah great job
fantastic it's a big big deal and GE
healthcare US and Canada president
Everett Cunningham Thank You Everett
Thank You Everett before going further
let us send our love to all of the
families that have been displaced by the
flooding near Midland I spoke to your
governor this morning and we've sent
some tremendously talented people out
here we have FEMA and we have the Army
Corps of Engineers and they can do
things that frankly nobody else can do
the Army Corps of Engineers what they do
so they're very good at rebuilding dams
that are busted or blown up or for
whatever reason bad things happen but
Americans are praying for Central
Michigan and we're going to take care of
your problem the governor and I had a
great conversation this morning and at
the appropriate time I go and see the
area that we'll be fixing we're going to
help you out we signed a emergency
declaration very quickly very very
quickly
and we're gonna help you out very
quickly also in recent months this state
and this country have faced great
challenges here in the Detroit area you
were hit hard by the virus very very
hard in this area as one people we hold
in our hearts the precious memory of
every person that we have lost and we've
lost too many one as too many we lost
too many it came in from China and it
should have been stopped in China they
didn't stop it they should have stopped
it and there's one grateful nation we
proclaim god bless our
health care workers they've done an
incredible job they're like warriors
they're like warriors I want to thank
all of the nurses and doctors because of
the virus Ford was forced to stop
automobile production for the first time
since World War two that's something but
you did not despair your company
leadership called up the White House and
asked the most American of all questions
how can we help true I said that's nice
that's very nice every one of the
workers in this project volunteered to
take part in the greatest
industrialization and mobilization
project that our society has done the
American people have done in our
lifetimes the company founded by a man
named Henry Ford good bloodlines good
bloodlines if you believe in that stuff
get good blood they teamed up with the
company founded by Thomas Edison that's
General Electric it's good stuff that's
good stuff and you put it all together
there they're all looking down right now
and they'd be very proud of what they
see you began the production of 50,000
life-saving ventilators a number that if
you go back just two months I would say
most people would say it would be
impossible to believe the media's back
there and they would have said a couple
of months ago the creation of that many
mint ventilators would have been not a
possible thing every single one of these
ventilators is made in the USA with
American Heart American hands and
American pride just as your
great-grandparents produced more than
one Model T every minute just as your
grandmother's and grandfathers produced
a beef beet 24 you did the b-24 bomber
so pictures in the back that was quite a
weapon that's quite an incredible weapon
b-24 bomber and just as a Ford f-150
normally drives off the line every 52
seconds you quickly mastered this
complex new machine a ventilator is a
very complicated delicate B
expensive machine 1 month-ago 4 it had
never built a single ventilator and now
you're a world leader it's a pet you
adopted the designs of a company that
was building just 10 a week but a very
high quality ventilator and very soon
you'll be producing one new ventilator
every single minute it's an absolute
amazing achievement and you're really
helping now beyond the country helping
other countries throughout the world we
have 188 countries that are fighting
this terrible enemy and ventilators are
something it could never you can do
cotton swabs you can do all of the
things can even do testing but
ventilators are a whole different lot
it's very tough great job thanks to you
we'll stockpile over 100,000 new
ventilators in the next few months and
have offered over fourteen thousand to
friends and allies all around the world
and they desperately need them just this
week I spoke to five countries they
called me is it possible to get
ventilators to them and I'm sending them
over I want to recognize just a few of
the exceptional Americans who made this
historic feat possible Keith pastarino
is an electrician here in Roseville
Keith please tell us what you've done
how you like it come on up let's see
Keith oh look at the case
Thank You Keith love to grab him and
shake him but I guess we can't do that
guy well on behalf of Ford and the UAW
welcome mr. president
Keith pasterino I'm electrician when I
first heard the news that my plant was
going to be building ventilators it only
took me a minute to get a hold of my UAW
and then I decided that this was my
opportunity to serve my country so on
the first day as a volunteer we went
full speed seven days a week 12 hours a
shift I would go home sore bruised had
blisters was bleeding had trouble
sleeping just just because of the pains
of that day but I kept coming back
because this is a great nation and I
couldn't say that I'd be more proud of
my co-workers for their efforts and
their sacrifices to build these fine
Ford ventilators respirators face masks
and face shields thank you this has been
a absolute honor and a blessing and god
bless you sir thank you very much to you
thank you
great job great people we're also joined
by Gary Brabant a quality technician
Gary come on up Gary
[Applause]
Thanks
good afternoon Thank You President Trump
for the honor to tell my story my name
is Gary Brandt and I'm a fourth
generation Ford Motor Company employee
my grandfather's worked for a Ford Motor
Company during World War two and my
father retired from rasen Ville after 41
years I always knew growing up I wanted
to work for Ford I am very very proud of
the part of a part of the ventilator
project and the amazing job done by Ford
in the UAW team here I had anxiety when
I received the call to volunteer I
didn't want to get sick or take it home
to my family however upon arriving here
on the first day I felt safe due to the
new policies and procedures put forth by
our UAW health and safety team it's a
great feeling to know everything we are
doing here and each assembly we make is
saving somebody's life Thank You mr.
president
and God bless america thank you very
much thank you Gary
Thank You Gary very much with us as well
as Adrienne Price who has helped lead
this effort as one of Ford's top
engineers highly respected come on up
please hey drew
[Applause]
thank you really thank you for the
opportunity to represent my friends and
colleagues who've been involved in
project Apollo I'm honored to be part of
a team that over the last few weeks has
been able to produce more than 17
million of these face shields 13 million
surgical masks 32,000 pressurized
they're purifying respirators and here
at the Ross infest Ross anvil facility
produce a ventilator every 60 seconds
these feats are a testament to the
skills and capabilities of the men and
women at Ford Motor Company and our UAW
and other partners who have come
together to do what we could do to
support the battle against Kovan 19 Ford
Motor Company and its employees are
always prepared to step up and do the
right thing to support those in need but
most particularly in times of
significant national crisis I believe
these acts are part of the DNA of our
company and are inspired by both forward
family and our continuing history of
service personally I'm proud to be
playing a part in supporting the brave
men and women who are on the front line
every day putting themselves at risk to
help others and as I stand here today
surrounded by these awesome
american-made cars SUVs and beautiful
trucks I'm so pleased that our
facilities and dealerships are safely in
operation and serving the needs of our
current and maybe future important
Lincoln customers Thank You mr.
president I brought plenty of them
I bought plenty of them thank you Andy
I have a lot of those Lincoln's that's
great thank you very much
that Lobel pandemic has proven once and
for all that to be a strong nation
America must be a manufacturing nation
we were bringing it back 600,000 jobs
previous administration said magnifier
shirring we're not doing that it's gone
from this country they were wrong
600,000 jobs until we had it turn it off
and now we're gonna turn it back on like
never before you'll see numbers that you
didn't even see the last time we're
going to rebuild it quickly it's gonna
happen very quickly we're already seeing
indications of that Larry Kudlow gave
some numbers that were really inspiring
this morning based on what we're hearing
and seeing true national independence
requires economic independence from day
one I've been fighting to bring back our
jobs from China and many other countries
today I'm declaring a simple but vital
national goal the United States will be
the world's premier pharmacy drugstore
and medical manufacturer bringing our
medicines back
[Applause]
and many other things too we must
produce critical equipment supplies
pharmaceuticals technologies for
ourselves we cannot rely on foreign
nations to take care of us especially in
times of difficulty in previous decades
politicians shipped away our jobs
outsourced to our supply chains and
offshore in our industries they send
them abroad and we're bringing them back
and we've been doing that long before
this crisis bringing them back that's
why we have so many plants being built
all over the United States that make a
beautiful product call cars bringing
them back you see it
I told Prime Minister Abbey of Japan
she's got a Shinzo you got to get it
back got a better we have many Japanese
companies now building car companies
here said you got to bring them back
we've had deficits with all of these
countries for years and years and years
they were ripping us left and right we
had no idea we had no leader that
understood what the hell was happening
but now you do I said you got to bring
them back we made a great deal with
South Korea we made a great deal Japan
with 40 billion dollars Japan is putting
into the United States not to mention
all of the plants that they're building
the South Korea was a terrible deal and
we made it good Hillary Clinton actually
made that deal she said it's going to
produce 250,000 jobs and she was right
it produced 250,000 jobs for South Korea
not for us wasn't too good was it but we
are bringing it all back to our country
and it started long before this happened
and maybe that's one of the reasons this
happened maybe people weren't so
thrilled with what was going on but we
had the greatest year in the history of
our country and have it again very soon
in this administration we know that it
matters where someone and something
where someone works on something or
where something is made as we've seen
today companies like you a great Ford
and workers like you are a national
treasure I can sit afford to be a
national treasure I consider you to be
national treasure the talent because
that talent and culture and commitment
to winning are irreplaceable your
patriotism cannot be outsourced your 117
years of incredible manufacturing
heritage cannot be replicated anywhere
else in the world the talent I see the
talent I know what talent is I
understand your world and I understand
your business that's why in my
administration we live by two simple
rules by American and hire American
and we have another rule that you may
have heard on occasion it's called
America first we didn't have America
first we had America last under previous
presidents they were more concerned with
the world than they were concerned with
their own country my first week in
office I withdrew from the job wrecking
trans-pacific partnership which would
have destroyed the auto industry I don't
know I didn't ever ask you about that
bill I mean I think you agree oh you do
would you please stand up and just not
that you agree that's your industry bill
would have been destroyed
had that deal gone through and not only
yours by the way but other countries
would have been very happy so I don't
know I don't know how the hell these
unions aren't endorsing Trump instead of
the standard Democrat a Democrat that
doesn't even know where he is we
renegotiated the catastrophic deal with
South Korea to preserve the protective
tariff when foreign made pickup truck
trucks you know the chicken tax they
call all right you know what the chicken
tax is most profitable thing you have
you know why because of the chicken tax
that was expiring a year ago and I got
it extended because of that tax it's one
of the most profitable products you live
for that product right I kept my promise
to replace the NAFTA disaster with a
brand-new US MCA which is a fantastic
deal for a country tough new
requirements under the US MCA ensure
more cars to be built in American plants
by American labor and even labor
endorsed it but you know the big thing
is you'll lose it all you Caron does you
weren't going to have a car industry
left now people aren't going to be
moving back to Mexico they're not going
to be moving back and you're gonna have
it the other way at the same time we
preserve our relationship Mexico's
actually been very nice our border is
the strongest it's ever been
we're up to over 200 miles of brand-new
beautiful border wall and that 200 miles
is pristine nobody comes through this is
a serious wall it's a serious wall and
it's incredible what we've done there
too we had the best among the best
months we've ever had
and now when somebody comes across we
bring them back we don't go through five
years of litigation in the other days or
the older days not so long ago if they
stepped a foot into our country they
ended up you had to be Perry Mason you
end up in a court case and it took years
you release him into the country by law
and then you say come back in five years
for your trial and only the very stupid
people came back about two percent they
didn't come back why should they come
back they were released into our country
we don't do that we don't do that and we
want people coming into our country but
we want them to come in through merit
and we want them to come in Legally it's
very important I'll continue to fight
for us Auto Workers as we rebuild our
economic strength or strategy for a
phased and responsible reopening
protects those lives those American
lives those high risk American lives
from the virus while allowing those at
lower risks such as young healthy people
where they just have a much much lower
risk we've learned a lot you're a
certain age you have a problem with
diabetes or you have a problem with your
heart you're a prime suspect for this
horrible disease it's a it's a terrible
thing so we've learned that young people
do very well very well incredibly well
older people especially older people
that have problems they don't do well at
all so we have to protect those people
and we want to get everybody now safely
back to work and we're going to do that
I spoke today about our churches our
churches are closed and I said CDC I had
a great conversation I said how people
want to go back to church on Sundays and
our churches want to take care of their
parishioners there people that go to
worship and you're gonna see something
come out very soon about opening up our
churches a permanent lockdown is not a
strategy for a healthy state or a
healthy country our country wasn't meant
to be shut down
we did the right thing but now it's time
to open it up and never-ending lockdown
would invite any public health calamity
to protect the health of our people we
must have a functioning economy and as I
said and I'll say it a hundred times
we're gonna have an incredible year next
year right at the beginning even our
fourth quarter is going to be very good
there's a tremendous pent up demand and
that inclusive cars Americans who need
and want to return to work should not be
vilified they should be supported
unlike many politicians and journalists
for those who are a living with their
own two hands working remotely is just
not an option you don't have the option
of doing that our plan emphasizes safety
and protection for returning employees I
want to commend Ford along with General
Motors General Electric Fiat Chrysler
and so many other companies a lot of
them in this area for blazing a trail to
safely restart America's economic
engines you are demonstrating that we
can open our country while taking
precautions like social distancing daily
medical screenings strict hygiene you
can get tremendous numbers of very quick
temperature checks who ever heard they
aim a camera right there in two seconds
later they tell you your temperature
more accurately than the old days where
you put it under your tongue for two and
a half minutes this is a little better
but you get temperature checks and I
want to thank you all for leading
America back to work you look at states
like Florida Georgia and many others
where the numbers have actually gone
down they're open but the numbers are
going down and very substantially down
with your help in our policies this
country is poised for an epic comeback
this is going to be an incredible
comeback watch it's already happening
within the next year we are going to be
exceeding any expectation and I've had a
good gut feeling about a lot of things
including running for president I said I
think I could win and I guess I was
right
everyone here today and by the way I
think we're going to do better the
second time and it's very important that
we win the second time or everything
that we've done including manufacturing
jobs all this it's going to be not in a
very good position everyone here today
is the heir to a majestic a noble
tradition you walk in the footsteps of
those who built the Motor City in the
1920s and 30s who stocked the arsenal of
democracy in the 1940s and who set the
standard for automotive safety and style
in the 1950s and 60s and Beyond and even
today bill was showing me some of those
cars it's incredible I want to buy one
then I heard the price I said forget it
I said I'll use one occasion right but
what a car that is it what a car our
friends and allies marveled at these
triumphs of American industry and our
enemies learned that nothing can stop
the strength and power and grit of the
American worker nothing just like
generations of Michigan manufacturers
before you each of you is done your best
for America in its time of need you love
your country you love your country so
much now you have a critical role to
play in forging a new legacy of American
greatness that will inspire and endure
for generations to come
it's a very important time in our
country's history in our country's life
because of you the Ford name will
forever stand as a symbol of American
excellence innovation quality and
craftsmanship and because of you America
will be strong and healthy and
prosperous and free for many many
decades to come
I want to say very powerfully very
strongly god bless you all god bless
america I'm proud to be here I'm proud
to be with Ford bill thank you very much
everyone thank you very much we'll be
back we'll see you a lot good luck John
James thank you for being here we're
gonna have a great Senator John James
thank you all very much thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]